ludwig got swatted again the popular
streamer was hosting a chess tournament
on his channel when the lapd entered his
home weapons drawn generally i'm pretty
fine
the initial part is kind of scary
but then it it's it's quickly
overwhelmed with uh with an annoying
feeling a sense of annoyment of course
ludwig isn't the only one this has
happened to recently a swat wave seems
to have hit the streaming community with
ice show speed aid and ross and carefuls
all getting the cops called on them xqc
famously had to move because he was
getting swatted pretty much daily almost
every day
the the police came to our house uh with
the full squad as scary as the whole
situation must have been all things
considered ludwig seems pretty chill
about the whole thing if that's what you
want is 55 minutes of my sunday taking
up now if you get your rocks up on this
good job alright this will be the one
thing you do then you die then that's it
pp poof bye bye gg no read it feels to
me empty